and the Syrian war is the most serious humanitarian scourge of
this 21st century. Yes, it is
a fight that calls us all together, but
Finn is only susceptible to being affected
by dialogue, never by weapons, until then,
it is up to us to guarantee humanitarian aid to the
11 million people  that depend on it
to survive and it is necessary to guarantee
open channels so that
humanitarian workers can get this
help without any kind of
use by politicians or
any kind of conditioning This is
a scourge that worries us that
questions us every second and every second
which we have to give the answer because to
a generation that is losing in Syria